Anonymous says,
how do I deal with the fact that I'm a
pedophile and should I tell my family
and friends it?
Um,
I can't answer the second part of that.
Should I tell my family and friends
because I don't know your family and
friends and I don't know how you would
go about telling them.
So I can't make a piece of,
I can't make any advice about that or I
can't offer you any advice about that.
Um,
I would say that if you have the
opportunity,
you should probably go speak to a
counselor or priest or someone that you
trust,
um,
because you're going to have to figure
out how to deal with that and,
but you should also maybe,
and that's about the best I can do with
that.
I'm not an expert in the treatment of
pedophilia.
And so I can't offer you any great
clinical wisdom,
but I would say that you need a plan.
You need to plan and you have to,
and I would include in that plan the
absolutely catastrophic consequences of
not regulating that behavior properly.
And you should really think it through
because that pedophilic impulse,
let's say,
could lead you into seven different
sorts of hell.
You and whoever you happen to tangle up
in it,
and you might want to avoid severed
diff.
You might want to avoid seven different,
seven different forms of hell,
and in order to do that,
given the proclivity that you described,
then you're going to have to have a
plan.
Now,
look,
lots of people have impulses that they
have a hard time controlling.
You know,
alcoholics can't drink alcohol and
cocaine.
Addicts can't take cocaine,
and most people can't.
What manifest untrammeled sexual
behavior.
And so it certainly within the capacity
of human beings to regulate impulses
that aren't in there or other's best
interests.
So I wouldn't regard it as a hopeless
pursuit,
but it does seem to me that it's
something that you might want to talk to
someone you trust about because it's,
it's a complicated issue and it's a
proclivity that's likely to lead you in
a direction that would be,
let's call it sub optimal.